[Music]
foreign
what are the two Godzillas that we will
have in 2023 let's take a short look
into what is in store for us this coming
year and try to assess what kind of Big
G versions We will be seeing on screen
let's get to it
Godzilla zero as per reports and Twitter
posts from Toho there will be a new
Japanese Godzilla movie a live action
film that will be released in November
next year on the birthday of the Big G
himself the last full movie made by
Touhou on this king of the monster is
the 2016 Shin Gojira which is focused
heavily on politics and also on the Big
G's hyper Evolution nevertheless it
seems that they would go on A New Path
in this upcoming movie
many asked a question will it be Shin
Godzilla part 2 well the answer is a big
no as much as we love shin and this
strange iteration of Godzilla Toho is
definitely going on a different
direction with the giant monster Shin
Godzilla ended abruptly as the king of
the monsters went into a deep freeze a
prolonged hibernation with small new
forms of himself were emerging from the
tail if the movie was to continue with a
sequel it would have become more of a
cosmic horror themed storyline and less
about the walking nuclear disaster that
is Godzilla
so will it be another origin story well
as per the early filming and the casting
of extras it seems that the next movie
will be set in the late 1940s or maybe
the early 1950s meaning that it will
coincide with Godzilla's first ever
appearance in the big screens and the
monster timeline which is 1954. the
title itself which although might be
tentative is still a big clue as to what
the story is going to be Godzilla zero
will most definitely focus on the
nuclear attacks by the United States
during World War II and how the big G
either awakened or was transformed due
to that event and yes it will be sort of
a reboot to the original maybe even a
modern remake with better CGI and live
action
then was the design this is the one
thing that most Godzilla fans are
anticipating what kind of Godzilla will
it be will it tackle along the design of
the most of us or will it take a
different approach and look towards a
more classical shower and heisei looks
they only clue to this is the Godzilla
zero logo which shows a g that is in the
shape of Godzilla himself and if we are
going to go by that and it will look to
be adapting certain design features from
the master verse and also have a very
long tail akin to shin and singular
point and have a fat torso like that of
the anime Godzilla Earth himself but we
can only speculate and that's about it
for Godzilla zero
anyway let's get to the other Godzilla
flake that will be shown next year not
the Godzilla vs Kong part 2 the sequel
that will be released in 2024 but the
most diverse Godzilla series titled
Godzilla and the Titans filming of the
series started in Australia and went on
to different locations globally so this
will be an ever expanding monster verse
World building storyline and as per the
stated gist it will focus on Godzilla
after his battle against the mutos in
San Francisco and a family that will go
on around the world with Monarch to
discover the hibernating Titans
so even with this version not much has
been revealed but again we do know that
General look and design of this Godzilla
but will it be the 2014 version or the
newer 2021 design
so let's take an educated guess on a
timeline and say that you know this
series will follow Godzilla immediately
after the battle against the murals in
San Francisco so at the very start we
will see the G-Man in his 2014 iteration
but since the show will be between 2014
and 2019 king of the monsters therefore
we might be lucky enough to see his
battle against the muto Prime and a
transformation into the ultimate version
after his dorsal plates were Shattered
by his rival the prime
and asked to the question of which
monsters will Godzilla be facing in the
show well the only documented battles of
him in the timeline between 2014 and
2019 would be against the muto Prime
which is the ultimate form of the two
mirrors seen in the first film it would
be the first time we see this Titan in
live action the battle that would change
Godzilla's body structure and change
both his nature as well as power and
then as we have seen from the
novelization of king of the monsters
there was another Titan by the name of
Mark Yeager that was killed in the
oceans with scars on the body bearing
the mark of the atomic breath so it is
very likely that we will also see this
fight under the Seas
and the last question is will it
showcase An Origin story maybe as
flashbacks as the storytelling would not
go back to the prehistoric times the
discovery of the new tyrants and
information about their past is more
likely to happen as to the origin of the
G-Man I would think it would be up to
the movie the sequel to Godzilla vs Kong
that would have to bear the burden we
would probably see Behemoth Methuselah
Sila again and the others like mukile
and bembe but will we see them in an
active state or in a deep Slumber will
be up to the showmaker's wish
so I hope you have enjoyed this brief
video on the two Godzillas that will be
appearing next year
do hit the like button for sport And
subscribe but most of all smash the Bell
icon for regular updates on new videos
right here on this channel till the next
one take care fam